hallo mein name ist khan meine damen und
herren ihr seht ihr schon im titel
eingeblendet wir spielen heute ein spiel
namens vier bilder ein youtuber bzw 4
bilder 1 so wie es hier gerade
eingeblendet steht hier seht ihr oben
wieder irgendwo werbe video eingeblendet
war das ganze eine kooperation mit
google play ist und fahren die leute vom
pool play wieder gesagt ey luca suchte
doch einfach noch ein spieler aus dem
place torhaus und spielt einfach also
ihr habt videos und ich habe eine neue
kooperation
wir klicken einfach mal auf die app
durch
geil direkt meine lieblings youtube das
ganze läuft folgendermaßen ab ich kann
jetzt hier eingeben beispielsweise plw
blog shit verdammen das weil es die
falsche antwort jetzt können wir die
buchstaben hier wieder wegmachen und
jetzt denke ich beispielsweise einfach
mal auf hinweis verwenden und jetzt kann
ich indem ich für münzen mirbeth tipps
kaufen und ich habe gerade 25
das heißt meine damen und herren ich
strenge mich jetzt mal ganz toll an und
würde sagen es ist baby und zwar baby
das heißt dafür bekomme ich jetzt ein
bein und muss jetzt fortfahren klicken
der nächste youtube auch wieder sehr
sehr schwierig wir sehen hier ein
mikrofon der echte sneaker und sein auge
beziehungsweise augenbraue
da würde ich mich jetzt mal ganz weit
aus dem fenster lehnen und sagen das ist
apd haben wir schon wieder ein köln
bekommen aber freunde eine ganz kurze
ansage von mir ich will nicht sagen dass
ich der beste youtube finden ist und
dass ich es bin dabei ich bin all wissen
meine damen und herren das heißt ich
sage jetzt zu euch ich werde jeden der
nächsten youtuber hinkriegen sonst
beende ich dieses video das heißt wenn
ich den nächsten youtuber nicht
hinkriegen solltest dieses video einfach
vorbei ist
das hier ist auf jeden fall um
spielt hinaus aber er ist ja nicht mehr
um gespielt splc so ungespielt wieder
einen coin bekommen aha das ist
konkreter geehrt
so haben wir das ende vorne nk haben
bitte gib uns eine bewertung das gefällt
mir sehr dieser app bürgerkriegen die
sogar im place tor jetzt von mir eine
bewertung und zwar fünf sterne am place
de könnt ihr euch aber selber mal
umschauen freunde ich habe hier übrigens
keine vorgaben bekommen von google
treiben das ganze übrigens mit pixel 2
auf und ich nutze das gerade mehr als
ein normales handy aber das geile am
place de ist halt ohne spaß endlich
wusste dass jetzt gerade nicht sagen
aber wenn man sich eine app herunterlädt
beziehungsweise wenn wir noch einen
drauf geht man was einem außerdem
gefallen könnte und dadurch findet man
so viele krank geile apps aber freuen
ich würde sagen wir machen wir weiter
mit unserer challenge und zwar grund kam
mehr hingekriegt wir das ist babys
beauty palace die eag ee sodann die
haben wir auch ein christlicher fort
fand das ist ja dass in 63 oder 120 ich
tendiere mal zu 21 also insgesamt auch
hingekriegt
oh mein gott alter wer ist das denn ich
weiß es nicht ganz so genau ich würde
mal sagen schuldienst blg aber ich
wusste nicht dass der aus italien kommt
das hier ist den meine damen und herren
das sieht man ganz einfach ans kinn und
zwar warum ist da wie oh days
eingeblendet
achim lettmann preis gewonnen die ngr
dena ist richtig wirklich noch
fortfahren
m
war das bild nicht schon
simon gerade die wm ist dieser youtuber
wird fortfahren
green day wird alter ohne spaß ich gucke
köln und so auch sehr gut dass dieses
bild green day wird mit drin ist die
außenseiter sind zwar nicht mehr richtig
aktiv auf youtube verdammte scheiße
nicht zwei es sind zwar nicht mehr so
richtig krass aktiv auf youtube ich
glaube die man macht ein paar sachen
sascha keine ahnung
hey
also der sagt mir jetzt gerade das
außenseiter nicht richtig jetzt
vielleicht muss ich doch mit doppel s
machen anstatt dann schaffen es also aus
dann hier noch mal gut scharfes s hat er
irgendwie nicht so richtig drin wieder
einer meiner absoluten lieblings
youtuber was den content angeht finde
ich aber ich würde sagen das ist krieg
sieht man an der österreich viel
leichter da
dieser hätte kann mich nicht schlagen
hier haben wir
ich weiß nicht was für eine flagge ist
es dass tschechien oder der slowakei
fest dass irgendwas anderes ist bin ich
ca das größte die größte 0 in erdkunde
skript dass sie es
das würde ich mal sagen weil das drei
leute sind und die affen und da unten
auch crime scene steht also crm und dann
noch das g11 crime war auch richtig hier
haben wir melina ich weiß nicht warum da
köln und der nordpol gezeigt wird
b
essen das ich würde sagen sarrazin
nachdem ich mir jetzt mal die buchstaben
so ein bisschen angeschaut habe und es
ist richtig
dann haben wir hier julia encke das hier
ist paola parolari heißt die maria oder
maria keine ist würde ich sagen maria
also paola marie haben wir auch richtig
dass hier ist die allseits bekanntes
lipsky show so und shw
was
alter
wieso ist das nicht richtig ich klicke
jetzt mal auf hinweis
böse einfach die frage mal aufschrift
tv.de ok alles klar das hier ist german
eigentlich heißt der german letzten aber
hier ist es anscheinend german let's
play einer der längsten namen die wir
bisher in dieser challenge hatten das
hier ist head of blood würde ich mal
sagen ich habe es tatsächlich nur er
kann wegen berlin weil in berlin sind ja
echt eigentlich relativ wenige youtuber
und ich kenne ich jetzt auch nicht aus
wer sohn die goflex auf seinem kanal
zockt und so marcel zu dem scorpion ist
beck am start meine damen und herren
hier vorne haben wir ihnen eingeblendet
das ist auch relativ easy und zwar easy
a 1 auffahren die gehalt
absoluter liebling stupid meine damen
und herren
man muss ja sagen hätte letzter zeit mit
einer krankheit zu kämpfen aufgrund von
drogen et cetera pp bin ich an der
stelle gute besserung wie der pablo aber
ich mag dein konnten trotzdem noch immer
nicht so gehört blicken wir weiter auf
fortfahren haben hier als nächsten
youtube du ich weiß den wieso ist dass
ihr kurs
es wird schon schwieriger die sache ist
ich kann ja auch nicht schießen
ich kann ja jetzt nicht googeln ja zwei
youtuber zirkus haare freunde ich trinke
jetzt mal ganz doll rum und schaue mir
eine video damit ich 45 points bekommen
ein paar sekunden später ich stehe jetzt
einfach auf hinweis verwenden und lasse
die frage auflösen halli galli
ey
zirkus halli galli
das ist doch das ist doch kein richtiger
youtube kanal
okay ich bin wieder im rennen ich würde
sagen das dürfte jetzt einmal machen und
kein zweites mal materna banana banana
altana altana banana die altana banana
als richtig wegen der banane
oh wow
da sind viele gegner gerade laien uwe
eingeben ist auch richtig klicken wir
fortfahren das sind die space flug
das war tatsächlich frühjahr mein
absoluter liebling skandal auf youtube
habe ich nahezu jeden tag geschaut also
geben was mal anschauen und richtiges
beim space rocks auch rasiert ich frage
mich halt die ganze zeit wann ich komme
ich möchte auch in so einem spiel drin
sein das hier ist hans verbot meine
damen und herren aber ich habe echt
lange zeit gerade noch gezweifelt ob es
wirklich sein könnte weil oben rechts
ist kein doppel ps sondern normales
peace das hier ist die misses wie lothar
v lgn ist es wieder kam war auch richtig
dann haben wir hier bushido okay ist auf
jeden fall auch ein krasser youtuber das
game
david der gombold angeschmissen komme hd
ist auf jeden fall auch in der app drin
absoluter favorit von mir in diesem
spiel oh mein gott ftr
luca noch hinter
luca genauso heißt mein youtube-kanal
freunde das hier ist der nächste
youtuber das sm
ich würde allerdings sagen meine damen
und herren wir sind schon ein level 37
ich habe diese challenge geschafft bis
auf halligalli da hätte ich eigentlich
verloren aber da konnte ich mir zum
glück noch ein video angucken und ein
paar points sammeln sonst würde ich an
der stelle das heutige video auch
beenden meine damen und herren wenn es
euch gefallen hat das gerne mal einen
like da er mehr findet ihr oben eine
umfrage eingeblendet ob ihr mehr mobile
games säen wollen also ob ich so was die
das jetzt gerade öfter auf meinem kanal
bringen sollte ich mega es aber eure
meinung ist gefragt sonst würd ich sagen
meine damen und herren wenn ihr
tatsächlich das video jetzt bis zum ende
angeschaut habt und alle youtuber bissen
und erraten konnte dann schreibt man in
die kommentare youtuber haye und sonst
kommen wir jetzt zu einem teil dieses
videos auf das sehr sehr viele freunde
und auch familienmitglieder und auch
zuschauer und auch ihr die youtube user
darauf gewartet haben nämlich das auto
rollt es rein freunde das was ihr vom
video das was jetzt hier vom
hier können jetzt hier meinen kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten mal einen
shop ausschenken jetzt findet ihr zwei
andere videos und benny schon abonnent
seid könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken
dann willkommen die benachrichtigungen